[Musique]
nous sommes le 2 mai 2010cette bonsoir
bienvenue pour le 7 8 et les invités
émission dédiée à celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département
invité aujourd'hui jean yves maximilien
et nous expliquera dans un instant le
projet de reprise de la librairie jms à
saint cyr l'école via une société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif une
entreprise de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
l'activité va pouvoir se maintenir avec
chantal de grave petite fille de déporté
nous reviendrons aussi sur la cérémonie
du souvenir organisée ce week end à
travers la france elle était présente à
trappes dimanche dernier et puis
rencontre également enfin d'édition avec
david shivers violoncelliste pour le
concert de l'ensemble continuum en
l'église notre-dame de versailles le
vendredi 5 mai à 20h45 bonsoir jean yves
maximilien et bienvenue sur ce plateau
futur gérant de la librairie à jms à
saint-cyr-l'ecole futurs gérants car le
projet de reprise que vous portez est
encore en cours un petit peu de
d'élaboration va y venir mais déjà nous
vous avons invités pour comprendre le
modèle économique que vous défendez qui
va permettre de sauver des emplois on
parle de trois postes dans ce cas précis
l idée c'est un modèle qui répondent aux
exigences de l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est à dire comment ça va
fonctionner ce projet alors en fin de
compte ce n'est pas très compliqué
simplement c'est une entreprise dont
gérant elle est partie en retraite et
potentiellement deux emplois allait
disparaître
de plus le sien ça faisait 3 et donc
nous sommes je dirais le projet a mûri
pendant une petite année est la solution
la plus adaptée pour une reprise pour
permettre aux salariés ne peuvent au
pouvoir tenir tous les tenants et les
aboutissants de du projet c'était que
ces salariés soient propriétaires en
partie de leur entreprise et vient une
société coopérative d'intérêt collectif
ça leur permet même s'ils n'ont pas la
totalité des parts sociales d'avoir une
majorité 50% de voix façon à pouvoir
décider de leur choix dans leur
entreprise et mobilisation citoyenne qui
va permettre à permettre de sauver se
demande et l'économie
oui puisque il ya pratiquement voulait
plus d'une vingtaine de sociétaires qui
se sont mobilisés pour apporter du
capital et racheté le fonds de commerce
et pouvoir donc pérenniser les emplois
et pérenniser l'activité
ça veut dire qu'après ces citoyens qui
sont mobilisés qui ont apporté du
capital peut-être actionnaires et touché
quelque chose alors en activité où on
appelle ça sociétaires plus exactement
et donc dans le système coopératif les
les profits sont réinvestis dans
l'activité via des réserves
impartageables et qui permette d'avoir
de données du potentiel d'investissement
et de développement à l'entreprise et il
peut y avoir éventuellement des
dividendes mais c'est très minime haut
niveau et l'objectif surtout quand on
achète une part c'est pas de spéculer
sur cette page c'est à dire que
concrètement si un jour
certains personnes certaines personnes
vont sortir du capital elles sortiront
ont leur remboursera les parts avec une
hauteur de l'augmentation du niveau du
coût de la vie est un placement avec un
taux d'intérêt relativement faible mais
en tout cas c'est malgré tout
emplacement même s'il ya un petit risque
au final si l'activité pour un risque
quand on arrive mais il ya une volonté
de s'impliquer dans la société et de
sauver ces deux trois postes dont il
était question n'en parle d'une
librairie qu'il n'arrivait pas à trouver
de repreneur le gérant était en
difficulté c'est à dire que cette
activité était été condamné comme bien
souvent aujourd'hui alors l'entreprise
est viable aujourd'hui mais
un certain âge on a envie de partir en
retraite et ce qui est louable et donc
c'est vrai que ça fait deux trois ans
que le gérant n'arrivent pas à trouver
de repreneur est bon quand
j'ai appris ça en fin de compte je me
suis posé pas mal de questions
c'est vrai que faire disparaître une
librairie c'est quand même un lieu de
culture un lieu de dieu de savoir et sur
un territoire c'est important ce genre
de d'équipement et donc c'est ça qui m'a
amené à réfléchir à une solution de
reprise dans l'esprit que je porte d'un
point de vue social et
et économique qui n'est pas de détenir
le capital de l'entreprise pour en faire
des profits mais détenir le capital de
l'entreprise pour la faire développés se
développer l'activité de l'entreprise va
peut être évoluer le lieu aussi parce
que là pour l'instant pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas cette librairie al jms
elle se trouve à saint cyr l'école elles
pourrait déménager en fonction des
locaux et puis l'activité évolué un
petit peu parce qu'elle était
spécialisée dans le livre scolaire
oui ça alors il va conserver sa
spécialité parce que c'est quand même
une base importante du chiffre
d'affaires il faut pas le négliger pour
autant comme je le disais tout à l'heure
une ivresse est un lieu de culture un
lieu des changes et le projet consiste à
la déplacer dans un local plus grand
pour permettre que ça devienne une vraie
librairie généraliste qu'on puisse il y
accueillir des auteurs qu'on puisse y
organiser des conférences sur des thèmes
liés bien sûr à la littérature l'a lié
au livre et que ça puisse venir devenir
un lieu d'échangé où on puisse y lit à
intégrer des partenariats avec des
associations locales des
tout un tas de même par exemple
typiquement on a déjà commencé à
travailler avec les les structures
culturelles locales de saint cyr de
fontenay bibliothèques théâtres cinémas
etc
une dernière question où en est ce
projet concrètement il pourrait voir le
jour qu'en alors enfin ce gérant partir
à la retraite tranquillement
concrètement alors de toute façon même
si il va céder la gérance il va rester
pour me soutenir dans la reprise de
l'activité
un certain temps et normalement on
devrait pouvoir boucler la passation
courant n'est et donc les locaux que
l'on envisage pour être investi à peu
près à partir de l'automne parler de
cette initiative on en reparlera bien
sûr dans nos différentes éditions du
journal on viendra vous voir sur le
terrain une toute dernière question
néanmoins plus politique parce que vous
êtes aussi à conseiller municipal
d'opposition
si vous étiez anciens pour celui ci pas
de gauche sur saint cyr vous avez été
par le passé aussi candidat front de
gauche aux élections locales
peut-être une réponse rapide tout de
même parce que nous sommes en période
électorale il ya un temps de parole et
d'égalité entre les candidats est ce que
dimanche vous allez voter bien sûr
j'irai voter
macron parce que je pense que le
fascisme est plus dangereux que le
libéralisme
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
poursuivons cette édition du 7 8 les
invités plus de quatre millions de
personnes sont mortes des suites de la
déportation dans les camps nazis c'est
pour se souvenir de ses victimes et que
des cérémonies sont sont tenus partout
en france le week-end dernier à
l'occasion de rencontrer l'une des
petites filles d'une personne déporté à
auschwitz elle est aussi présidente de
l'association républicaine des anciens
combattants par des membres de cette
association et sept au micro de nicolas
landry en tant que petite fille de
déporté quel regard vous portez sur
votre grand père justement
ah ben moi c'est un rôle c'est un regard
d'admiration parce qu'il s'est battu
tout ça toute sa vie sur la liberté
puisqu'ils étaient d'origine polonaise
qu'il a déjà été déportés une première
fois qu'il était porté une deuxième fois
et qu'il est mort en réalité à quelques
kilomètres de sa ville natale puisqu'il
habitait dans la région de cracovie pas
très loin de d'auschwitz et c'est c'est
quelque chose d'affreux de sud est de
venir s'est libéré en france il a fait
il a été volontaire pour la guerre de 14
et d'être déportés comme ça à quelques
kilomètres de chez lui c'est quelque
chose qui a été
moi j'ai une admiration pour lui pour
tout ce qu'il a fait dans son pays un
temps timorée en quoi le devoir de
mémoire de transmission notamment aux
jeunes générations
est il important parce que à un pays qui
lui ouvrit sa mémoire qui oublie son
histoire recommencer les erreurs on le
voit aujourd'hui la montée de comme avec
les élections qui se posent tout ce qui
se prépare là pour dimanche prochain
c'est
c'est un cas de conscience pour des
milliers j'irai même des millions de
gens parce que tous ces électeurs qui
sont maintenant devant un choix
difficile
c'est compliqué et si on roule on remet
pas en mémoire ces événements qui ont
fait le lit de la famille de l'open on
oublie on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un oubli de cette mémoire de ce côté là
les jeunes ont conscience de ce qui
s'est passé durant la seconde guerre
mondiale durant les périodes de
déportation non parce qu'aujourd'hui on
enseigne de moins en moins à l'école
c'est de moins en moins abordé donc il
ya une perte de mémoire de ces jeunes
qu'on ne construit plus sur l'histoire
de france tels que telle qu'elle s'est
passé ce phénomène est il un danger
ben oui parce que quand je voulais dit
c'est la mémoire c'est quelque chose
d'important
si on veut pas remettre commettre les
erreurs du passé il faut conserver la
mémoire de ce qui s'est passé avant
sinon ça ne sert à rien d'avoir subi des
tortures des arrestations des sans
regarder le souvenir pourquoi elles ont
le sens de la delà de l'histoire qui a
eu à ce moment là si on l'oubli on
recommence le mali 0
comme ça
[Musique]
jo
la mort
au ce
[Musique]
il y avait une émotion lors du chant des
marais qu'est ce que ça représente pour
vous cette ce champ j'ai moi j'ai roulé
comme je suis petit hic de déportés
alors je veux pas dire j'ai eu cette
chance mais j'ai passé tout mon toute ma
vie mon enfance et ma jeunesse dans les
colonies de la fédérale 2 l'iphone du
rpi des déportés donc c'était un champ
que systématiquement on apprenait en
colonie donc c'est pour ça que je suis
même pas besoin de regarder les paroles
je le connais par coeur parce que ça ça
a bercé toute mon enfance sur sept et et
dense est que dans ces colonies là on en
a on expliquer bien aux enfants
quelle est l histoire de leurs parents
ou de leurs grands parents à cette
époque là un mode musique à présent avec
un concert le 5 mai prochain l'ensemble
continuum qui se produira en l'église
notre-dame de versailles l'ensemble
basée dans la cité royale a été créé en
2016 avec un répertoire qui va du
baroque au moderne l'un des fondateurs
dhabi cheevers violoniste franco
américain participera et nous l'avons
rencontré lors d'une répétition c'était
du côté de magny les hameaux au micro de
mélanie poker david gilbert ce bonjour
alors vous êtes le directeur de
l'ensemble continuâmes et avec ce cet
ensemble vous êtes en concert le 5 mai
qu'est ce qu'on pourra y entendre déjà
alors on a un très beau programme de
musique italienne baroque sur une
thématique de l'eau donc chacun des
compositeurs qui seront présents dans le
programme donc il ya du vivaldi qui le
plus célèbre qui étaient vénitiens
locatelli galoper
et alessandro scarlatti et chacun de ces
compositeurs ont vécu près de l'eau
locatelli est mort à amsterdam et
notamment ont vu une contact peu connus
d'alessandro scarlatti qui s'appelle
olimpia avec un sous titre soulas punta
del mar et c'est veut dire sur sur les
rivages de la mer donc voilà c'est ta
mythique de l'ol est prêt si tu
présentes sur sur toute la soirée et
votre invité pour ce concert c'est
notamment claire des vonau tout est un
petit mot sur elle voilà bah claire et
maltaises donc elle aussi elle a un
rapport avec avec vinyle
oui j'ai oublié de mentionner qu'on joue
aussi du locle qui est anglaise donc
voilà encore une fois la thématique de
l'eau claire est une magnifique soprano
qui qui la chance d'avoir une très belle
carrière qui a beaucoup travaillé avec
william christie à la travailler au
festival de glyndebourne
elle a fait beaucoup de choses donc on a
beaucoup de chance de l'avoir avec moi
je ne sais pas ce groupe c'est lançant
le continuum
c'est très récent vous avez fondé en
2016 ouais pourquoi déjà abbas était un
projet que j'avais en tête déjà depuis
longtemps
auparavant j'étais plutôt dans la
musique
enfin dite moderne c'est à dire que je
jouait du violon sur sur instruments
modernes
j'ai pris goût et passion pour la
musique ancienne
j'ai découvert ça progressivement on va
dire depuis à 10 ans à peu près j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec avec john eliot
gardiner qui m'a aulaqi imam et puis les
musiciens qui l'entourent m'ont beaucoup
influencé
c'est vrai que j'ai fait mes études j'ai
grandi en angleterre et
musique ancienne fait vraiment partie du
du paysage musical c'est vraiment très
très ancrée très donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de musiciens qui font les deux
qui font autant de la musique
contemporaine par exemple que de la
musique ancienne
c'est la fin du set 8 invités pour ce
soir replay sur notre site internet
très belle soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]